[Musique]
les élections sénatoriales ont lieu tous
les trois ans en septembre
les sénateurs sont élus pour six ans au
scrutin universel indirect
c'est à dire qu'ils sont élus par un
collège électoral de 160000 grands
électeurs depuis 2011 le sénat est
renouvelé par moitié le nombre de
sénateurs élus dans chaque département
varie en fonction du nombre d'habitants
les sénateurs sont élus au scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours où un scrutin
proportionnel la proportionnelle
concerne les départements dako moins
trois sénateurs de scrutin majoritaire
les départements où sont élus qu un ou
deux sénateurs en septembre prochain
170 sièges vont être renouvelés